We'll have positive 3 for the first one, negative 3 for the second one, and
negative 51 for the third one. Great work, if you've done all three of those.
Now if you weren't quite sure what to do, that's okay. Let's see how it's done.
For the first problem, we know that the a value's really equal to 3. So, we're
going to square this 3. Our b value is really squared to 6, so we'll square the
square root of 6. 3 squared equals 9 and the square root of 6 squared is 6.
Then we just subtract these two numbers to get positive 3. For our second
problem, the a value is really equal to the square root of 2. And our b value
is really equal to the square root of 5. Squaring this square root leaves us
with 2. And squaring this square root leaves us with 5. So 2 minus 5 equals
negative 3 and this last difference of squares, will have a as 2 root of 3 and
b as 3 root of 7 and here's where we want to be careful. We want to square this
2 and this square root of 3. We know 2 square root is 4. And the square root of
3 squared is 3. There's a multiplication between this number and this radical,
so after we square there's still multiplication between this number and this
number. We square 3 root 7 to get 9 times 7. Next we multiply 4 times 3 to get
12 and 9 times 7 to get 63, and then subtract to get our final answer of
negative 51. Now I think that's pretty incredible that we can take something
that contains radicals. and pop out just one number